the jurogan experience there's too many
of them it's amazing they're still alive
isn't it so many of them when you see
one how [ __ ]
ancient they look yeah they're dinosaurs
they're legit dinosaurs right
yeah and they're all over the place we
were talking the other day about uh
disneyland
in florida that over the last few years
they've pulled hundreds of alligators
out of disney world
well dude that girl got eaten yeah a
little kid yeah yeah
imagine you're two-year-old you remember
remember what it was like when your your
kids were two
like you love them so much you're so
protective of them mm-hmm
yeah they're so vulnerable and they see
them getting killed by an alligator
yeah there's a [ __ ] lawsuit oh god
i'm sure but they probably just paid
them off i mean disneyland's just
printing money or disney
world disneyland's been shut down for a
[ __ ] year
is that the one in california yeah
they're open again now but they were
trying to sue
to try to get open again you know they
had the strictest laws
in california when it came to covid but
it didn't have an
impact on like the number of cases it
didn't have the impact on the number of
deaths
yeah like in comparison to florida where
they just went buck wild and wide open
right it's like florida did better
mm-hmm
with their [ __ ] [ __ ] alligators
wandering around
now they got the everglades are filled
with [ __ ]
anacondas pythons pyel pythons that
killed all the mammals
they did this study on mammals in the
everglades they used to have
raccoons and marsh hairs and all these
different deer
nothing wow nothing everything's gone
it's all pythons
it's pythons and alligators it's so bad
now that pythons are eating alligators
oh i saw a video of that it's crazy
there's a there's a photo a famous photo
look at this florida python challenge
gets underway with a new ten thousand
dollar prize
yeah they're trying to what they really
should do
is uh first of all california which is
so [ __ ] dumb you can't buy python
goods
why because they're [ __ ] they've
just decided that's an exotic and we
don't want it
it's just political it's completely it's
it's it's all about optics
right like the idea that you're gonna
have these exotics
like why is it okay to have like
lamb skin or sheep skin why is that okay
yeah why is it okay to have uggs with
sheepskin inside of them that's okay
it's okay to have a leather jacket it's
not okay to have a [ __ ] python
yeah like what the [ __ ] doesn't make any
sense
yeah there's no logic to it at all you
can't have pythons and meanwhile
what they should do is make it available
everywhere and and make it so that it's
commercially fishable
that you can go or huntable you can go
out there and collect these [ __ ]
pythons if it's very valuable
they'll at least be able to put a dent
the problem is it's all swamps
so they can't even find them they're
never gonna put a dent that's
that [ __ ] is that ship is sale look at
this
185 pound burmese python captured in
naples
might be the heaviest in florida history
how big
that i think it might have been 16 feet
damn they also got a this was a female
they got a male 140 with it
i saw one there's one somewhere that how
big do those [ __ ] things get
like what's the biggest python i was
looking at something on the
internet and i was like is this real
because it was said they found a 30-foot
python
and it was eating dogs oh yeah
they get that big well it ate a [ __ ]
alligator
alligator according to this longest in
florida
uh 18.9 feet what about longest and like
uh i think this was in um
south pacific somewhere in the in asia
it's all pets 185 pounds is big enough
to eat a hundred and fifty pound
yeah oh yeah yeah this while you whole
yeah
yeah another thing they have in florida
that's everywhere is iguanas
everywhere yeah there's i've been i've
went down a youtube rabbit hole the
other day where people
hunt and cook iguanas in their backyard
wow
yeah because people who live on canals
they live near canals they uh they get
like a bow fishing setup
and they're out there shooting and
killing iguanas and they turn them into
chicken wings
wow yeah they whack their legs off and
they fry them
they fry them up and they batter them
and they make like these
it looks delicious like these asian
dishes this might be
that's it that's the one so 33 feet 33
feet holy sh
that's exactly the one where was that it
says it was
excuse me brazil yeah jesus christ
oh my god look at the size of that thing
holy [ __ ] all right you can't fake that
what does that thing
eat dogs that's what they're saying
giant snake found in brazil 10 meters
wow oh my god look how fat that thing is
that is so crazy that that's a real
creature
that lives alongside us uh imagine if
you're just [ __ ] hiking
and you see a 30-foot snake staring you
down i mean that is
so big wait that's an anaconda
is it python and anaconda the same no
different 33-foot anaconda
yeah well that was that [ __ ] movie
with jennifer lopez remember
anaconda where they were even bigger
because they they think that there used
to be
giant anacondas in the amazon that were
even bigger than that
like what is the biggest like the myth
of the giant anaconda is something
that's apparently
it's in dispute whether or not they're
real things i i was trying to find the
biggest python which i did see it does
this say a reticulated python can grow
up to 30 feet
but anacondas i believe it's bigger i
typed in biggest snake and that's how i
got that
which was anaconda i think they think
that at one point in time
anacondas would get to a hundred feet
long
like there's it's all meth it's hard to
tell what's horseshit or not
but there's like photos of ones that
people took from planes
where you see this thing that looks like
a telephone pole
but a 100 foot long telephone pole yeah
making its way through the water
like that big wow [ __ ]
i don't know if it's real though dude
the alligators get [ __ ] big in
florida too my uh
my mom lives down there and she plays
golf and there's a
a a pond that has [ __ ] alligators in
it like
on the golf course on the golf course
they just wander around
so she was standing on the edge of the
pond one day
her ball is near the edge and for some
reason she decides to play it not
kick it out the fairway she plays it
from the edge she takes the club back
and she loses her balance and she
[ __ ] falls in the water
over her head goes under and then goes
to get out of the water and she's
she's like pulling herself up but it's a
muddy slope and she can't get out she's
like [ __ ] flailing on the side
and somebody helps her out and she got
out of the water and
i mean she she was so scared
that when she got out she started
laughing and she was laying on the side
of the pond
my mom's like five foot two oh my god 78
years old
oh my god imagine that's how she went
out
yeah golfing near a pond getting spun
around in circles by an alligator
what's the worst animal to die at the
hands of if you had to choose
probably hyenas wolves hyenas because
they eat your guts first
yeah yeah if you see hyena videos
they're they're pulling like gazelles
they pull their guts out
they're eating them guts first coyotes
do that too they eat you [ __ ] first
oh wow the [ __ ] yeah a friend of mine
who is a wildlife biologist was telling
me about
um there there was a girl who got killed
in canada
a few years back by coyotes and the
particular area where she was in
she was a really um a petite girl and
she apparently was a very talented
singer
she was a talented like folk singer or
uh yeah i think that's what it was i
think she was a folk singer
and uh she was just going for a walk
yeah
and uh she got killed by coyotes which
is super super rare yeah but he was
saying that is
one of the worst ways to go because they
they try to kill you [ __ ] first
her death is the only known fatal coyote
attack on adult as well as the only
known fatal kayak
coyote attack on a human ever confirmed
in canada
wow she was 19 years old in nova scotia
it's [ __ ] crazy catch new episodes of
the joe rogan experience for
free only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience